ich habe jetzt gar nicht mitbekommen
aber im bundestag haben sie heute das
digitale versorgungsgesetz debattiert da
ging es um medizinische apps und online
sprechstunden gegen den ärztemangel
ja warum nicht gerade so ältere leute
auf dem land hantieren ja gerne mit
smartphone und apps und so dass ich nie
ganz scharf darauf natürlich kann man
alles machen kann man alles machen
leider haben wir aber in der analogen
medizinischen versorgung gerade ganz
andere sorgen viele antibiotika wirken
nicht mehr ärzte schlagen alarm
europaweit sterben jedes jahr 33.000
menschen an infektionen mit
multiresistenten keimen
warum weil wir mit antibiotika um und
schweißen als werden die smarties
zwischen 2005 und 2015 ist der einsatz
um 65 prozent gestiegen
übrigens auch in der massentierhaltung
da wird das zeug schubkarrenweise in die
futtertröge gibt hier lecker keime
germanwatch hat im april stichproben von
hähnchenfleisch genommen bei netto in 58
prozent bei aldi in 75 prozent und bei
penny in 82 prozent der untersuchten
fleischproben und wir haben einen
gewinner
ja toll super idee für ein partyspiel
wer kriegt die verkeimte bulette
wir nennen es russisch roulette und
danach gibt es pharma schinken für alle
so ja wir lachen aber wahrscheinlich
wird das ein spannendes rennen die frage
ist was bringt uns herum der klimawandel
oder doch der multiresistente kein ja
geht ja schon in der bibel und kein
tötete abel denken sie da mal drüber
nach höchste zeit also neue wirksame
antibiotika zu entwickeln
problem fast alle großen pharmakonzerne
haben die forschung dazu eingestellt
weil die entwicklung kaum gewinn bringt
frage warum fördert der staat nicht
wieder die antibiotika forschung wie wir
das bis in die 70er jahre gemacht haben
das wäre mal echte daseinsvorsorge weil
wir sonst vielleicht bald nicht mehr da
sind
das bundesgesundheitsministerium
schreibt dazu es wolle sich dafür
einsetzen dass auf europäischer ebene
weitere anreize für die antibiotika
entwicklung geprüft würden ja wir setzen
uns dafür ein dass vielleicht was
geprüft wird
mit den antworten wir legen uns wieder
hin gut vielleicht hilft gegen bestimmte
kein wir ja auch eine app müsste man
ausprobiert und während antibiotika
manche nicht mehr helfen sind andere
medikamente gerade oft nicht mehr
lieferbar es wirklich war vielleicht hat
es auch schon gemerkt blutdrucksenker
asthma spray aber auch ganz profane
erkältungsmittel ibuprofen aspirin oder
der impfstoff gegen gürtelrose fehlen
seit wochen wir sehen jetzt hier das
aktuell 198 artikel nicht verfügbar sind
da haben wir einen bedarf main wegen von
fünf sechs packungen am tag von einer
entsprechenden packungsgröße und wir
haben zurzeit nur eine einzige vorrätig
so ein name den zur versteigerung kommt
die letzte ibuprofen 400 in ganz
deutschland bei 400 euro
hörig 500 euro komm ich denke ich erst
noch so
ja
[Applaus]
die sie verstehen
überlegen überlegen sie mal deutschland
hat eines der teuersten
gesundheitssysteme der welt und trotzdem
werden die medikamente knapp
für viele präparate gibt es halt nur
noch einen hersteller der seine fabrik
aus kostengründen gerne nach indien oder
china verlagert und am ende fehlt dann
sogar das zeug für die lokalanästhesie
es gab neun zeitpunkt da hatten wir
eigentlich keins von denen die wir sonst
routinemäßig einsetzen mehr zur
verfügung und das bedeutet ja
improvisieren am patienten
ja das sollten sie so einen patienten
natürlich haben wir denn sonst an der
op-schwester improvisieren bei
narkosemitteln werde ich mir das denn
bitte vorzustellen ach so natürlich war
es cool klar
tatsächlich kriegen bei uns immer mehr
patienten jetzt vollnarkose weil dafür
die mittel noch da sind
was gibt es denn überhaupt noch in der
apotheke die neue apotheken umschau ist
diese woche schmerzmittel sind alle und
wir zeigen die besten alternativen aus
dem bahnhofsviertel von klebstoff
schnüffeln bis crystal meth wer braucht
teure antidepressiva wenn er eine fips
asmussen kassette zu hause
und der hainberger tipp wie sie aus
einer alten espressomaschine ihrem
thermomix und ein paar metern
gartenschlauch eine astreine
dialysemaschinen bosse die neue
apotheken umschau jetzt als letztes
produkt in ihrer apotheke
wenn man die erste publikum
die bestätigen jetzt ist ein echtes
problem aber seien wir jetzt auch mal
fair es gibt durchaus themen wo unser
gesundheitsminister jens spahn handelt
er hat jetzt gerade entschieden die
krankenkassen dürfen weiter für
homöopathische mittel zahlen spahn ist
damit offiziell globalisierungs
befürworter 20 millionen zahlt die
solidargemeinschaft also weiter jährlich
für präparate die keine wirkung haben
die über den placebo-effekt hinausgeht
sehr emotionales thema ich weiß reden
wir darüber mit den gesundheitsexperten
der am ungesündesten aussieht mit olaf
schubert meine damen und herren
ich habe dass ich habe das oft selber
erlebt wenn auf einem berliner
spielplatz ein kind hinfällt kommen
mindestens drei mütter aus dem gebüsch
gesprungen und stopfen globo niederrhein
gibt es das bei euch im osten auch habt
ihr homöopathie hab tierheilpraktiker
wir haben ist sehr erfolgreiche aktive
also quasi keine praktika aber man muss
natürlich jetzt mal differenzieren viele
denken ja bei homöopathie ja da kann man
einfach alles reinwerfen das ist
natürlich falsch also ich nehme immer
erst mal so ein halbes globuli es wird
immer erst mal auf der stunden aus
gependelt und dann moral verklappt
vorsichtig und dann trifft ein jahr
hinweg also
ich tendiere er prinzipiell so zu diesen
alten hausmitteln also so etwas wie
wadenwickel kennt ja jeder
also wenn ich zum beispiel halsschmerzen
hat mache ich nur warten michael hirte
mit großem erfolg
dazu so lauwarmer leberwurst saft oder
eben das weiß ich noch von meiner
großmutter in der harten zeit nach dem
krieg da gab es eben keine antibiotika
wenn man da einen katar hatte dann wurde
desinfizierend gegurgelt mit eigenen
urin und immer die gleiche reaktion
ja ich meine wem der eigenen urin zu
eklig ist der kann ja auch den ohren von
jemand anderem nehmen ich bitte nur um
diese wirkstoffe die mit homöopathie
wissen ja auch einige zuschauer bedeutet
vor allem verdünnung ich habe hier mal
die entsprechenden bilder die so
genannte uhr tinktur wird immer wieder
verschüttet heißt das weil die wirkung
umso stärker ist je mehr die
ausgangssubstanz verdünnt wird also je
verdünnter desto wirksamer wie plausibel
ist das für dich also das wirkprinzip
lautet ja weniger ist mehr
noch weniger ist noch mehr und nichts
ist dann halt alles so
und die homöopathie das wissen nur die
wenigsten wurde ja vor über 200 jahren
von samuel hahnemann entwickelt in
sachsen anhalt lockte die hatten ja
schon vor 200 jahren im osten nichts wir
haben dann quasi das nichts verdünnt und
daraus medizin gewonnen und das magische
moment ist ja die hand verschüttung es
muss wirklich mit der hand verschüttet
werden
und das funktioniert tatsächlich also
wenn ich zum beispiel ein sonate gegen
kopfschmerz habe und wenn nicht mehr
dann mehrfach am tag von hand ein
verschüttet
also ja kopfschmerz ist wirklich fast
wie weggeblasen
das funktioniert aber eben wirklich nur
vom fachmann muss man der homöopathie
nicht zu gute halten dass an diesen
placebos aber unterm strich doch
deutlich weniger menschen sterben als an
echten medikamenten naja es gibt auch
den den den tragischen fall da hat es
ein hypochonder übertrieben und ist ein
placebo versuchen und ich bin dafür dass
man beides vereint also das positive aus
homöopathie und und pharmaindustrie also
dass man placebos entwickelt
hochdosierte placebos die aber trotzdem
nicht wirken dafür aber schweine teuer
sind
ja das könnte ich mir vorstellen und
natürlich müssen die dann eben richtig
erprobt werden damals geforscht werden
und da kann ja die pharmaindustrie dann
auch vertrauen zurückgewinnen
dass die medikamente eben richtig
getestet werden also jetzt nicht an uns
aber an denen wo ich jetzt sage ich mal
nicht auf den meter ankommt also an der
landbevölkerung michael beschreibt auf
facebook wilke du bist der letzte arsch
nur große fresse ich möchte ich mal
sehen wenn es hart auf hart kommt dann
schaust du dir in die hose warte ab ein
sprichwort sagt man trifft sich immer
zweimal im leben
mach weiter so mit einer großen fresse
wie können warten
sehr geehrter herr b man sieht sich im
leben nicht nur zweimal sondern jeden
freitag um 22.30 in zweiter oder hier
auf youtube wenn sie uns abonnieren